friendzone would bring on one of our
friends here at Fox on to the show DMI
is one of our best friends here at Fox
he's one of the people who helps this
place run he's worked here for years as
a studio tech he appears on your world
with Neil Cavuto and he has just written
a novel which I have read it's called
blood in the streets Dan joins us now so
impressive that you went by the way the
obvious question when did you write this
well geez I wrote this back it started
as a screenplay so I wrote this years
ago 2003 - maybe 2006 and then I ended
up turning it into a novel in 2012 and
that was around the time you read it and
you know you were so great to look it
over and all that and then it just took
a couple years of refining it before I
was able to you know get it out there to
market so to speak why did you write a
screenplay and then a novel I wanted to
make it a movie it was that it's it's a
the book in in its context now is very
cinematic am i I went to film school my
original idea was to make a movie and
write myself and as like say a Quinton
Tarantino would do so I wrote the
screenplay and then I just couldn't get
anybody to look at it for a couple years
so I didn't want to give up so I had the
idea well maybe it'll be easier turning
it into a novel and getting it published
that way so in 2012 I turned it into a
novel and then it took a couple years
and I finally got it out that way as
this brain spanking new novel blood in
the streets amazing set we're in New
Haven Connecticut where I was born and
raised in the 1970s I would say it's
kind of an homage to like you know the
70s gritty cop films and it's a fiction
but it is in a historical context that
within New Haven in the 1970s
interesting this is one of those books
that I think really has only been read
inside Fox News I keep getting texts and
emails but have you read this book it's
great yeah it's the rillette what have
people outside the channel read it
what's the reaction Oh people close to
me have and they've been messaging me
that they like it and I think they're
just you know maybe they're just being
nice it's just so weird because I've
been with the material so long in my
head that it's now surreal that I never
envisioned it now getting out there and
that people are gonna actually have a
reaction to it and come up to me and ask
me you're questioning me about it so
it's just kind of it's almost I'm taking
aback by that you know that people are
actually interested in talking to me
about it I'm like wow
I never saw this day coming so it's
surreal better than the alternative
I've written ignored books before
they're super quick are you writing a
sequel yes yes there is a sequel which
will be a prequel yes a sequel which
will be a prequel yeah a prequel to this
yeah I'm to dyslexic to understand what
that means but it sounds excellent and
I'll be reading that one too yeah it's
great to see doctor thank you so very
much congratulations man you're a
published author of a novel yes
not easy yeah Thank You Tucker